i'm getting better at it after five
years of false dawns hopes lifted and
chances slipping away the day they've
been longing for finally within their
grasp nazanin is coming home
for her husband richard it's the end of
an unrelenting effort to rescue her
before her release we sat down to talk
about his five-year ordeal and what
could be done to stop it happening to
others
but first went back to the beginning and
how the couple first met you know we
obviously came from different
backgrounds
came from iran i'd never been to run um
at that stage um she'd never been to the
uk until she'd been they've been there a
month or so but just it was a really it
felt like coming home like a really easy
kind of conversation where we just talks
and talks and talks
they married and had a daughter
gabriella
nazalene took her to tehran to meet her
parents but on the way out at the
airport iranian security moved in and
arrested her
we didn't hear anything for three days
um and and i think you know imaginations
really started to run wild as those days
went on listed my goodness where where
is she what what's going on
i just remember thinking this is crazy
like you know she went on holiday with a
baby
this cannot be about us this must be
about something else
nazaneen was taken for trial and trumped
up charges accused of plotting to topple
the regime
while richard could only sit at home
waiting anxiously for news i mean the
hardest bit to live with
was probably that early realization of
her sitting
in a windowless cell
being interrogated and blindfolded and
i'd done nothing about it
that's where i stopped sleeping for
quite a few days and it all
you know couldn't cost you anything and
couldn't get the wheels fell off at work
and so on how do you move on from that
how do you how do you deal with that
well
i mean campaigning in that sense so
actually starting to battle for her
it was the start of an untiring campaign
to grab the nation's attention and win
its sympathy
while the news from tehran only got
worse when she was in solitary
she went really depressed
feeling suicidal and went on hunger
strike and she was so distant
and cold on the phone
and i just remember
feeling like i'm not
i'm not connecting i'm not i'm not going
to think i'm not you know
part of the job of
with any spouse in any you know it's
just to be there for your other half and
just to be the person they turn to and
i wasn't doing that we were creating a
momentum where beyond sky
but it
it didn't count for anything in that
prison cell
in that prison cell she just felt alone
and isolated and that she was better off
dead
and you know it felt like i was doing
lots of
nice almost like
children's games to to you know feel
good about the campaign but
but the one thing that mattered was
keeping her going and
i was failing
the government's advice was to keep a
low profile and let quiet diplomacy take
its course
richard says he soon realized that would
only prolong their agony
i think they made a real mistake at the
beginning in downplaying what was
happening
and that standard hostage policy to you
know downplay it keep it calm and to
quietly negotiate you know you had a mum
and a baby picked up on holiday um it
took the government 18 months
to criticize anything in his treatment
in 18 months that's all sorts of torture
had happened in that time
he warns others like him that taking
foreign office advice to stay quiet will
only make matters worse given the
consequences and the consequences are
you get exposed to more torture
given those consequences you know can
you with a straight face to be given
that advice if you take that advice to
keep quiet that's what can happen you
will suffer more
uh absolutely absolute iron rule
you know
transparency
openness always protects you
always protects you
when you look at what nasa needs a
zigari ratcliffe was was doing it just
you know she she was simply teaching
people
journalism as i understand it there were
obvious missteps boris johnson badly
getting his facts wrong the most
notorious
but in his frequent meetings with
officials richard also sensed his wife's
welfare was not their only priority i
think one of the lessons
one of the lessons from our case that
comes across really strongly
is that the government's interests are
different from the victims
and and
you have to look after your own
interests
you have to look after your family's
interests and you have to battle for
them hopes were raised then dashed
nazaneen allowed out on furlough but
only briefly reunited with a daughter
gabriella at a parent's home in tehran
when gabriela came back to london to
start her schooling
richard had a new challenge to face
i was a fairly rusty parent and got a
real little girl um slightly
disconcerted and traumatized
and who didn't really know her dad and i
had to earn the right to be a parent
again um and you know meal times and
bedtimes were proper battles at the
beginning
with limited language as well um so you
know there wasn't much she could control
in life so she battled on the things
that she could so yeah i think it
it was a good
reawakening for me of normal life now
you're going to chop
[Music]
very good
it doesn't feel safe enough if i'm
honest
like it feels like it might happen but i
know
i'll just show you it's still quite a
messy quite a messy house
i i blame the two people on the sofa
away from the cameras and campaigning
richard has tried to keep life as normal
as possible for his daughter normal life
continues three different meals that's
the kind of harmonious household we are
using the phone to keep in touch with
nazarene thousands of miles away as much
as they can
together gabriela and he counted down
the days to the end of nazalene's
sentence but when it came she remained
barred from leaving the country
over time iran made it clear nazanin's
fate was linked with a debt stretching
back decades to the time of the shah of
iran for tanks iran paid for but britain
never delivered
richard lobbied for it to be paid you
can literally be tortured over british
government debt and that's not the
government's problem that's your problem
um it's really sobering um and it it
won't change without the law changing
but not everyone in government was
convinced foreign office minister at the
time alastair bert says paying back the
debt was subject to intense debate but
you were you were clearly pushing for
more progress and there were those who
were saying not so fast keep the brakes
on and how frustrating was that for you
i was more frustrated by the fact that
the iranians were holding nazim and they
shouldn't have done obviously but how
frustrated were you by that pace of
well
in government i would have said i mean i
i would have liked to have seen that
impediment removed but i did understand
the case about the sanctions and the
difficulties the united kingdom was in
relation to that and also the
difficulties have been seen to pay a
ransom richard ratcliffe is convinced
nazanin could have been released far
earlier it didn't need to have taken
five years
um that there are clearly
things that could have been done
differently
um
and and
you know it really should not have taken
five years that's an awful lot of our
lives
to have been lost
from the start says richard the
government has handled the iranians the
wrong way it's a complete mistreatment
for how you're gonna solve some of this
you need to treat this like organized
crime um so i i think for me
you know there are moments where where
yeah i'm crossed with individuals in the
way they've acted in certain ways um
i think nina's is yeah absolutely across
that she's lost so many years of her
life
um and there are consequences you know
it we don't get those years back but
also
you know
having any any more children
um
getting beyond emotion i mean there are
scars that will take a long time to cut
to heal some may be permanent and
that's our fate
nazarene's story has highlighted others
caught up in iran's cruel practice of
hostage diplomacy and britain's failure
to stop it
including south london retiree anusha
ashuri held now for three and a half
years his family equally critical of the
foreign office but we haven't seen
results and
you know it's it's one thing to sit
there and be polite and civilized and
listen to what they have to say but at
the end of the day
nothing's being done so how far can that
politeness take you how far can you sit
there and smile
america was able to secure its
journalist jason resigns release in iran
after just a year and a half he says the
uk needs to do more to tackle iranian
hostage-taking we need to move the ball
forward and call it what it is these
people
nazanin
anushay morad and others who are uk
citizens and deserve the full protection
and rights of their citizenship
uh are hostages
of a foreign state period point-blank
and richard warns without a change in
british government policy others will
suffer the same fate i think it's
something that's going to become more
dangerous for more people
if i'm honest i think
you know british
policy british hostage policy
british torture policy so the way we
you know decide whether how we protect
our citizens overseas
is dangerous for british humans and will
lead to people getting more and more
exposed oh there is an insect for five
years he's been stuck in a hellish
ordeal only now can he start planning
for the future in some ways i think it
does go back to normal and in some ways
things have changed forever
but it's too early to say at this point
you know which bits of those would be
the changing bits and which bits will be
the same
but i think yeah going back to being a
normal normal family
um being a bit more cheerful and um
learning to you know enjoy the small
things in life is where we'll start
because we came here last time didn't we
cycling and you were really fast i
should i sent my video he'll stop
campaigning he says nazanin's insisted
so we'll see less of richard radcliff
for nazanin they hope as they retreat
from the public eye and try to make up
for the years her iranian captors stole
from them dominic waghorn sky news